and I now welcome Robin
Grimes professor of materials physics at
Imperial College and a specialist
adviser to the House of Lords review of
nuclear research requirements for the UK
it is of course which I only learned
this morning the 33rd anniversary of the
accident at Three Mile Island how
appropriate I was got a lead on
Fukushima but you know basically you are
saying that despite the concerns about
accidents about terrorism proliferation
issues and even capital costs we do have
the chance to see another nuclear
Renaissance which could provide us with
you say a thousand years of energy he
really all comes down to the question of
cost so I'm going to start off with a
blindingly obvious comment which I think
is clear from what you've just mentioned
that nuclear energy is is controversial
I think that's probably one thing that
we can all agree on pretty much
immediately I've actually put a couple
of quotes up there at a typically sort
of protype quote and a typically kind of
antique coin like quote and I suspect in
common with many people in the audience
I could probably argue both Pro and anti
on both of those sorts of issues and I
think it's also true that we could
probably agree with the statement down
here as well that in general we can
think of new reactors being built in the
UK going forward but we are very
reluctant to differing extents to
accepting those nuclear reactors
relatively close to us and it's a very
interesting sort of debate and again we
could talk all night about just that
issue I suspect but essentially the
public understands or doesn't sorry
doesn't understand the complex issues
associated with running a nuclear
reactor and of course that's
understandable but I think the public
has a very strong sense of the risk so
it's one of the really crucial things to
try and have people understand is is
what what happens in a reactor how does
it work and so I think I'm going to turn
this react
wrong for a moment there you go and what
I'm pointing out here is something
relatively straightforward and that is
that's the nuclear reactor that's where
the reactions occur and this is a PWR
reactor and it's really the sort of
reactor with if we go up for a new-build
in the UK is the kind of reactor that we
would be building and you can see it's
exchanging the energy created in the
nuclear reactor here to produce steam in
the generator which turns the turbine
and so forth and get create the
electricity all of this part is pretty
common whether or not you are creating
the heat through a nuclear reaction
through coal through a gas even through
oil now why is it if it's so
controversial why is it if it's so
challenging that we're really interested
in it and it really comes down to
something quite simple so afraid we can
have to do a bit of physics first of all
you have to remember of this nuclear
reaction that what happens is there's a
tremendous amount of energy liberated
and that goes into the nuclear fuel it
disrupts the nuclear fuel and it creates
heat and it actually creates an
incredible amount of heat one of these
nuclear reactions this fission event
releases 200 million units of
electricity if we compare that to the
situation for a chemical reaction it
liberate one unit of electricity so
here's my other very obvious blatantly
obvious statement nuclear fuel is an
incredibly compact energy source and
that's really what is so attractive
about it from an engineering energy
point of view now uranium is certainly a
limited resource actually it's not
particularly scarce at the moment but
eventually we are going to have to use
it more efficiently at the moment the
way we use nuclear fuel we only use
about two or three percent of those
uranium atoms in the nuclear fuel two or
three percent that really is
astoundingly small amount so we're going
to have to learn to use it more
efficiently if it's going to be a
sustainable process and actually we've
been producing nuclear electricity for a
long time so here in this little
black-and-white photograph of for 200
watt
olbes and they were turned on on the
20th of December 1951 at the first
reactor to produce electricity which was
EBR one experimental breeder reactor
number one so immediately something
interesting it was a fast breeder
reactor it wasn't a conventional PWR
light reactor the first reactor to
produce electricity was a breeder
reactor by 1957 grid electricity was
being supplied with the UK the USSR and
the UK and the US by the way this is a
this is a picture of that first reactors
house just here and as you can see they
were obviously not too sure about the
technology because it really truly is in
the middle of absolutely nowhere I have
been and boy is it a long way from
anywhere and there you go but anyway it
was a fast Neutron spectrum so that was
a sort of a generation one type of
reactor in the UK we had these Magnox
reactors and indeed we still have one of
those Magnox reactors running until two
weeks ago we actually we had two running
following that we followed an advanced
gas-cooled reactor route which was a
very unique to the UK and most of the
rest of the world and followed light
water reactors and as I said
particularly a PWR pressurized water
reactor and psy as well be in the UK is
an example of a over pressurized water
reactor in fact it was the last one in
the West to be connected to the grid so
we have the most modern PWR reactor in
the West actually in the UK that's this
kind of reactor that has again if we go
in for new build it's the sort of thing
that we will be building the AP thousand
and the EPR are examples modern designs
of those p WR time technologies now this
is what I've been charged to talk about
to you this evening this is the
so-called generation four reactors so
the question is what does a generation
four reactor what sort of design is it
and actually it's not one design and in
some ways I don't think it's a very good
way of thinking about it because it's a
it's a series of different types of
designs all of which are supposed to be
all these wonderful things stated here
at the end which you can always state
when you've not actually built something
call me a cynic nevertheless you can see
the sort of timelines when these sorts
of technologies were thought about
according to this particular do a
document here but many of those designs
as you're going to see are really
evolutions on existing designs going
right back to EB r1 so let's have a
little bit of a think as to as to why
we're we're even thinking about such
radically different sorts of designs
different to our PWR and it goes back to
again to this use of uranium at the
moment most reactors use this open once
through type of fuel cycle the fuel goes
in it comes out you then have to dispose
of it and again two or three percent of
the uranium is used in the UK we have
been able to take out some of the
uranium and the plutonium that's
produced with a view of perhaps putting
it back in as mixed oxide fuel we never
quite got round to that and as a
consequence having gone part of the way
through we've ended up with an awful lot
of this material and the government's
just taken a decision that we'll
probably be using it in in these new
reactors if we build them the
alternative finally we could fully close
the fuel cycle by using fast reactors in
particular and in that case we could use
up to sort of 7080 percent so this is a
twenty to thirty times increase in the
efficiency of the use of the uranium
this also has the added advantage here
that if you remove the plutonium uranium
and the so-called minor actinides those
other elements around uranium plutonium
then the nuclear waste left over after
300 years has returned to its relative
radiotoxicity of the mine from which it
was taken in the first place if you do
what we've done in the UK there's a
partial recycling you can get to 9,000
it's kind of the pyramids so we have
built structures like that and maybe
Stonehenge but you know I'm not a
historian if you just do the ones
through cycle then you don't get back to
where you began for three hundred
thousand years which is a series of
glacial periods
so why on earth are we not doing that
and it's very simple it's the cost but
if we were to do that if we again are
able to spend that money then and again
excuse me I realize there are lots of
numbers here and that we could argue
about all night there's the ones through
for uranium but if we were to use it in
a fast breeder reactor we increase the
use and if we then include elements like
thorium in a fuel cycle then we have
something up to 2,000 years worth of
fuel at our disposal why don't we do
that again of course how much you
willing to spend those are the six types
of fast sorry of Gen four type reactors
and I'm going to just mention one thing
close fuel cycle closed fuel cycle
closed fuel cycle closed fuel cycle and
then these last two which would be used
in tandem with some of these other
designs to perhaps close the fuel cycle
they trying to do quite different things
I wished I had so much more time to
explain this to you which I don't you
don't okay thank you but different
reactors in different places for
different jobs one of the reasons I
don't like the idea of putting them all
into this gen 4 concept is that there
are also small modular reactors which
offer greater flexibility for grid
capacity limited risk capacity
environments for example and I think
those may well be built a long time
alongside but one of the other
interesting things is they all have
these marvelous names my favorite here
is the Toshiba 4s book super safe
smallest so my final slide how will gen
4 aid in a nuclear power renaissance how
could it
aid us I think it really comes down at
the end to this simple bullet point the
Gen 4 attempts to address key issues of
fuel sustainability passive safety
proliferation risk and offering
flexibility to develop passive systems
that can develop hydrogen orchid develop
electricity for other chemistry as well
as closing the fuel cycle and allowing
us to use the uranium
as we perhaps altered I'm sure the
audience will have lots of questions
about these these points these promises
by the gen four maybe just one quick
question I mean if we define our aim to
be to pretty much eliminate co2
emissions by mid-century and this
becomes commercially viable in 2030 and
then takes 10 20 years to build this
won't be part of the solution comes too
late doesn't it that is an issue I mean
it really is an issue and and you know
one of the things that I didn't
emphasize here is that you know there's
an awful lot work that needs to be done
on these types of reactor systems before
they really become commercially viable
except that if we think about for
example the a sodium core fast reactor
India will have a sodium corpus reactor
which will go online next year so the
different Gen 4 designs will become
available to us at different times and
can make a contribution in fact right
questions start in the front and then
I'm sorry I won't go to the back right
after keep it really short because we
are already beginning to run over okay
thank you
Craig Bennett director policy in
campaigns at friends of the earth and
low in thanks so much for that I start
off by just saying you know really
support the research into this who knows
where we're gonna be in the second half
this century absolutely so no problem
with that
but I would say because of these
timescales you know this is completely
irrelevant to making any difference to
climate change and therefore I would
argue is not a game changer in this
debate that's even just some a kind of
technical point of view of the
development of this but then you add on
the kind of social and economic things
you know that the nuclear industry has
had a whole history of over-promising
and under-delivering what nuclear power
station has come in under budget and
delivered sooner that it was supposed to
and we've seen that problem time and
again let's not forget that Margaret
Thatcher when she came into office
promised to build 10 nuclear reactors
and in 15 years she built just one and
she was a pretty determined lady so you
know there's a real problem there and I
think actually the biggest risk about
nuclear power these days is that we Bank
on it to help us solve climate change
and then it doesn't deliver and we end
up with coal and gas and we don't deal
with climate change so it's surely the
biggest problem and my real concern
which I'd love to hear your thoughts on
doesn't this all
deflect attention political will
engineering capacity and of course
investment from the vast number of other
proven options that will deliver at
scale quicker and cheaper let's not
forget that the cost of solar PV for
tonight was for 30 percent percent in
the last year gosh well we need a couple
of hours on on some of those and I mean
the numbers of the points that you make
I think are very valid as a matter of
fact I mean I'm not who are nuclear
energy type advocate at all you know I
think you have to be a realistic all big
scale engineering facilities have
problems all of them have failed to
deliver at certain times the issue of
learning how to build nuclear reactors
has indeed been a problem and if you
just look at the problems in Finland at
the moment of the Reaver reactor and
conversely you can look and look at the
Korean situation which over period of
time with an energy policy dictated by
government with the will to have an
energy policy delivers nuclear reactors
on time and under budget only at the end
at the beginning they had difficulties
but by the end they worked out how to do
it it is possible to do it it's same my
comment about the India situation there
is a there is a distinct will I think
the government needs to have and make a
decision about a clear energy agenda for
the UK so that people can make those
sorts of investments my worry actually
is as to whether you know actually
getting that the money to build the
reactors in the first place I think that
will be the reason that we actually
don't build nuclear reactors I think the
other things will overcome yeah which
brings us back to the whole issue of
pricing carbon but let me have two
ladies please because we haven't had any
ladies lady number one and then followed
by another lady there we go
last of those two questions thank you
I'm not sure I approve of being picked
just because I'm a lady but thank you
anyway I'm birth tailor I'm from the
Institute of Physics but I used to work
for the UK
and was involved in in cleaning up doon
ray and I'm just a wee bit worried about
history repeating itself in the sense
that Doon ray did produce two fast
reactors which worked but by the time
they were working the whole problem
about oh there's going to be a huge
demand for uranium and everything's
going to get terribly expensive and fast
reactors will be worthwhile had
evaporated because no big nuclear
program had happened there was no huge
demand for uranium and so sadly the
whole experiment was actually a
commercial failure well that's the clue
and I'll just finish it I'll be really
quick plus the fact that you were
closing the cycle with reprocessing and
dealing with some rather nasty chemicals
including that quit sodium current
creates a real cleanup problem I'm just
worried about getting back into the same
cycle
hi my name's Marie Carvalho from the
Grantham Research Institute on climate
change and environment and my question
has to actually talk about the carbon
intensity of the entire supply chain of
nuclear powers so if you were to look at
uranium mining to the processing to
using and also storing it for the long
the transport and storing and the energy
intensity of those processes along with
the carbon intensity can we really claim
that nuclear power is carbon free oh I
don't claim for a moment that nuclear
energy is carbon free not at all I claim
it's low carbon but it's certainly not
carbon free for all the reason that
you've just said and that one of the
problems is that there are many
different sets of numbers and I'm not an
expert in that particular area which put
you know nuclear energy slightly more or
slightly less than onshore offshore wind
and so forth so so I think there's an
awful lot of arguments and I would like
to see more work specifically in that
area so I think you know I I sort of
agree with you by saying that I don't
that's the first things I know we're
running out of time the second thing yes
absolutely
so there are two things that I know
number of things I didn't go through
first of all I actually don't think we
will be building gen4 react
in the UK anytime soon I think what's
going to really concentrate our minds is
life extension for a gr plant dealing
with the graphite problems and so forth
which I think you'll be probably
familiar with as well I think we will
then build increasingly evolutionarily
better PWR conventional PWRs we might
find ways of recycling multi recycle
marks we've got an awful lot of civil
plutonium that we need to deal with the
government's indicated that and so I
think that UK might actually come to
this a little bit later than some other
countries do I see that the shift in
nuclear Enterprise has moved to
Southeast Asia
very very strongly and I think we'll see
quite a lot of the developments in Gen 4
there but I was tasked we're talking
about Gen 4 tonight so that's why I had
to do look thanks Robin and sorry to cut
it short yet again it does feel like a
bit of a impossible these issues thank
you